j'aime bien gilles verdez parce que eh
bien il est tout à coup il se met à
hurler et jusque et par quelque chose
toi qui n'a blessé personne
et il est tout seul à se mettre en
colère les choses a assez assez mignon
est assez drôle sans aucun doute le nord
lille le semestre paul je joue chaque
fois cinq ou six fois par spectacle
céleste paul de lille
oui absolument
c'est à dire il y fait on a fait les
étiquettes magnifique c'est un slip
kangourou avec les raisins qui dépasse
puis la feuille de vigne c'est
magnifique et j'en ai fait un nul pour
le rosé avec deux grains de raisin et un
string entre les deux magnifiques aussi
et c'est un vin de france de pays d'oc
et il est magnifique je suis très
content on s'apprête à le commercialiser
si possible dans la grande distribution
de sur encours de rien mais qui dit
docteur je crois que je présente
lunettes et maggie je vous confirme pas
ce que c'est d'une banque
g
mais qui lie à sa femme je te ferais
bien l'amour ce soir ces mêmes animaux
qui chérit sa tombe mal parce que j'ai
des pertes blanches
ce mardi c'est pas comme moi j'ai du
diabète refaire des meringues et c'est
vrai que je suis tu arrive un peu vite